[Music]
et was on set at the taping of bachelor
in paradise is season forecast reunion
where viewers will see Corrine elympios
and Demario Jackson meet for the first
time since the show's infamous shutdown
we spoke to host Chris Harrison about
the sit-down and about the summer of
scandal
Karenin de Mario met for the first time
tonight did that go how you thought it
was gonna go at the end of those
conversations I had with each of them it
just felt like it wasn't complete and
they both wanted to sit down I think
they needed it am I still fully
satisfied with all this no you know as a
journalist as a reporter as a host I
would love to go further into all this
but there's a box I had to play in and
so with within that box I'd give myself
about a b-minus of how I had to handle
this and what we could do but legally
there's just certain things I could and
couldn't do what do you wish you could
do there's a lot of people I'd love to
talk to the third party I'd love to get
their take on this there's producers I
would love to sit down and talk to you
on camera there's a lot of there's
executives there's lawyers there's
there's a lot a lot of layers to this
that people will probably never know nor
do they probably need to because at this
point it's not that important but there
was just a lot of layers to this and
very little of it even had to do with
grinning to Mario so you can't legally
talk to that third party even though you
want to if I can make that happen I
would sit down with that third party who
filed the complaint for sure who has
seen the tape have you I have not
because I chose not to I know exactly
what happened yeah I was very I mean
there's not a detail that I don't know I
had the choice to see the tape and that
night and I decided not to the most
important thing to me was I treated
Corinne and Demario equally with respect
dignity cared for them made sure they
were equally taken care of I never
treated either one of them differently
and that was important to me watch
bachelor in paradise Monday September
11th on ABC